okay thank you so this this is a mixture
of various pieces of ongoing and joint
work with with yes / and an antique
ornate for moles so I'm colletion secure
protocols what what do I mean so so
things like that ws beats BTW what have
you this sort of thing and of course as
well no they're great right because
because they computationally you know
much more efficient and then f is ebay
stuff as these currently but on the
other hand they're not so great because
they need lots of interaction right at
me as you all know you typically bound
22 to a number round which is
proportional to the depth of the circuit
you're doing in communication is
something like number of players time
circuits eyes so here by the way i
should say i'm here i'm concentrating
on-on-on protocols that don't amortize
so I mean that there are lots of
protocols where if you allow the number
of players to grow with the size of the
computation in some sense then you can
get rid of that factory but but that's
not the focus you so and this is all
protocols that that are efficient in the
circuit size of the function of course
if you if you're not worried about this
if you're happy about the biasing
program size or something like this then
then you can do much better but bounced
but I mean that's due to keep a
practical eye on things I'm
concentrating on this thing ok so the
really hard problem here of course is is
can we really improve this significantly
and this is if you listen to talks by
this guy your valve this this is what he
calls the the fhc of unconditional
security and if you had his tox you also
know that that if you could really solve
this problem I mean like like really
break it down then then then several
breakthroughs would happen in other
areas as well so so all ready for that
reason it's it's it's it probably is a
really hard problem even better reasons
you Val thinks it's hard so therefore
really is hard right so so so therefore
I I don't have a solution for this but
but but we we have some partial answers
so put a little bit here and there and
and I think maybe part of emissions is
not so much to make you fall off your
chest because of the results it's more
trying to get some interest in this that
there are some things you can at least
say
even if you you're not going to solve
this this big problem tomorrow and so so
the first thing I want to talk about is
it's not really any of the complexities
I was talking about just before like
rounds and communication but message
complexity so so what if I what if I
want to count messages so I don't care
how long the messages I just want to
kind of many investors you have to send
it say to compute some non-trivial
function securely so so think of every
every play as an input bit I want to
compute the end everybody does the
result and and once that require it's
it's related to but of course not the
same as one complexity and and before I
say anything about results and if you
start thinking about how do you actually
count messages it's not entirely trivial
because if you think about synchronous
protocol that has slots where you know
in every round each player can send
something to any other player if he
wants to so you know suppose the
protocol sometimes but not always sends
a message in a given slot and should we
always charge for that time slot I mean
you might say we should write because
the absence of a message is also signal
right however i'm going to say i'm only
going to charge the protocol for
messages that actually set so I'm
talking about lower bound so it just
makes the lower bound strong it right
and and that there are some positive
results i also have and they are for for
the other the other notion where where
every slot counts actually if you use it
ever okay so so what's the result
basically so for this for this end
function i was talking about if you have
n players and t7 score options you have
to send basically omega NT messages to
do this that's a more precise version
coming up in a moment yes
well because because I mean that the
same message can could result from from
just constant round I mean this is say t
is is a constant times and then they get
quadratic attend here which is what
you'd get if you do constant round
everybody talks to everybody in those
rounds the clothes would be that you
know I i I'd talk to emit he talks to me
I talk to him we go on for a while and
then there are many rounds right so in
particular more precise we solved three
players once my arms corruption I want
to compute the auditory input bits
everybody does result then three
messages are necessary and six meses
sorry and six meses also sufficient and
that s construction that we have based
on on the private simultaneous message
protocol of fuel and eyal and so so why
should something like this be true well
and first of all any player if you think
about it so this is justin totally hand
waving but yeah yes so so well at the
beginning I have my inputs I have to
give my input away right so of course I
have to talk to at least t plus 1
players because otherwise I mean the
answer is going to corrupt those T
players I talked to it that's one thing
and then also just head waving well I
learned the result right so I have to
receive some message later on to
actually get the result right something
which is not quite so obvious is that
message that gives me the assault cannot
revive too early intuitively because if
it arrives before my input becomes
determined then I could together with my
other bodies that are also corrupted
sort of pretend we have it had a
different input computer view that's
consistent with this other input and the
same messages from from the others guys
and now compute the output for a
different input of mine which is not
supposed to be legal right so so so
therefore if you can't well say we can't
send and receive operations so for every
player there is T plus one of those for
those T plus 11 messages that I saw used
for my inputs and then two more named it
was sendin they receive for the message
that gives me the output
okay so so this is where we play it so
you know it's n times t plus 3 and i
divide by 2 because i counted sends and
receives so i divided by 2a get a number
of messages yeah yeah maybe you said
this but is the model that the message
pattern is fixed before the protocol
start it doesn't have to be so so this
this also hosted this is a wealth front
of the file of what I was trying to
shovel under the world because I know
that I'm but but but it doesn't have to
be actually so so this is of course pure
hand waving yes this is for passive
because you say that that I have to at
least wait for my input to be determined
otherwise I cannot up to reach change my
but no this is my head so I'm a semi
honest guy i can take the information i
learn and try to compute whatever I can
from that so that the point is the
following if if if I receive a message
that gives me the result at a time why
my input is not determined from from
from the communication I send out right
now I can do a thought experiment
whereas they suppose my input with
something different now i compute a view
that's consistent with with the this
other input and what I've seen so far
which must exist because otherwise my
input would be the servant for the other
guys so that that's to be possible and i
can compute the output given a different
input of my original one and that's
that's not allowed so that i don't i
don't actually change mine put in the
actual protocol by this to a for
experiment so so anyway the this can be
formalized although it takes more than
10 obviously yes
well I think it relates to toward to
what a demise I think that that actually
it it doesn't have to be the case that
the message pattern is determined in
advance it can be populistic that's why
I'm saying no not necessarily I mean
that the park has allowed to to make to
make you know decisions on the way and
who talks to who I do yeah all right I'm
not in fact even entire lease Europe but
but I think the result is is written
down for perfect go at this what you
actually get is almost this so you get
you get the what i wrote down but
there's this subtraction of one and but
then it's a ceiling so no more lee it's
the same thing you know i'm not sure if
that is that it's just because I proof
they think it's not good enough for or
its but at least in a lot of the cases
it is right answer it turns out so
fatigue is one at least and n functions
in deterministic log space this is
exactly tight so so that's that's where
the diva solve for n equals treaty and T
equals one comes from so that that
generalizes to you know this this this
case for one corruption and lots of
players potentially yes
no no no because I want to count
messages I I don't care how long they're
okay so so that's that's one thing so
what about a number of rounds then can
we say something so so it's probably
hard in general but but something we
looked at which has connections with
what I just told you about to some
extent and can can we if we don't know
how many rounds we always need for
everybody maybe we can reduce the bank
complexity for some players so so so a
lazy player here so i'm going to divide
i'm going to allow myself to divide the
set of players in lacy players and
active players so lazy player some guy
like this so what he does is he sends
initially a message to all of the acts
of guys that he falls asleep the other
guys do stuff and at the end he receives
a message from all the acts of guys and
then you should be done he learns to
assault and Andy type the overall
protocol is secure in the standard sense
okay so this is this is this is a little
bit like the client-server model that
some of you probably know about but the
difference is for the client-server
model we usually say well there's some
fraction of the service that can be
corrupt and any number of clients can be
corrupt this is not what we're saying
here we have the entire set of players
that see corruption is allowed and those
two options could be you know among the
passive lazy guys or it could be among
the acts of guys in some distribution
that we don't know so one result here is
for malicious corruptions and it's 3t
plus one you can have a general protocol
web 2t players can be lazy and and the
main problem there I don't have time to
prevent details but but the main problem
is that so that this model is this point
to point chance there's no broadcast
given now of course you can you can
simulate broadcast with that setup in
general but the problem you get is that
when when T players leave and don't want
to do much then can you do broadcast
though because there's only 2 2 to t
plus 1 players left right but you can do
some pre-processing it turns out if you
think carefully about it you can kind of
let these guys as part of their first
message not just
send something that is about their
inputs but also something that will kind
of allow the other guys to pretend
they're still there it's the new
broadcast so that that's the intuition
at least so that that was for the
previous thing this is ative yeah so
that they're so also at most D players
could be lazy you can also show that and
there's a similar result for semi honest
well of course and it's then to t plus 1
and still T players could be lazy and
that was salt the fact that most T
players could be lazy in the semi
islands case actually follow this
message complexity bout that I was
giving you before because you if if
something too good to be true happens
then you can do some simulation argument
resulting in a tree play protocol that
can compute the end with with too few
messages okay so so that's that's one
set of results and that's that that's a
paper that's your work with yes but
isn't actually so then I'm going to
switch gears a little bit and talk about
different set of results that is where
that's going in with yes / so here the
idea is let's look at those protocols we
actually have all those protocols that
go gate by gate so so if we can't if we
can't bound communication around Cindy
an oval for protocols maybe we can do it
for those protocols the fold is same
design pattern that we seem to be using
all the time right so so gate by gate
protocol it's basically the protocol
that follows this dis pattern that we
start by setting up secrets earrings for
the input values then we saw us the
circuit every time we encounter a gate
for which we have secret shares of the
two inputs we do something and we end up
with a sharing of the output value and
the idea is that that this doesn't
variance that says every time I handle
the gate I have the secret sharing of
the output value and that secret sharing
is in some sense a constant form of
secret sharing that is that I mean if
it's sameer the the the degree is not
allowed to grow it has to be something
like that allows me to continue and also
the that sharing of this value on the
wire is the secure sharing in the sense
that it only contains information about
that value of
this is why I can and of course at the
end open the the values on the output
wires okay so so for non protocols again
if I if I say it's a constant number of
places not allowed to grow with the
number of with the width of the circuit
say it's basically enzyme circuit size
and and you know circuit depth number
Rous so so the question is is is this
optimal for gate by get protocols for
some formalization of what that means
that this question can be asked of
course both honest majority and for this
almost majority with pre-processing
because I mean the things we know like
you know tiny oaties beads etc they have
this form to write so as a warm-up so so
to be a little bit more precise about
what i mean by gate by gate well it's
one that uses what I call a
multiplication gate protocol so that's
that's the sub protocol the hands of a
multiplication game so I'm saying it
takes as input two sets of shares shares
of a be in some field it returns yes of
a time speed possibly a different secret
share scheme I don't really care about
whether you know even a and B could be
shared in different schemes and and
first set of she has comes out and a
different scheme again but I'm going to
demand at the same threshold holes so
trace your old seat eco options and as
for the input so this this model is the
way we do we do say show me a secret
sharing and the protocols we locally
multiply we do something to reduce the
treasure back to T and also this is what
I said before revealing the outputs yet
to reveal nothing more than a times B so
that's that that's the kind of sub
protocol that we seem to be having all
the time maybe wed pre-processing maybe
without so so again and the claim is now
that any such multiplication gate
protocol must send at these T messages
likely do you think about it that's
that's not really hard to prove it all
it's it's it's easier than you might
think at first in fact so so it's that
the idea is simply that if you had such
a hypothetical thing that communicated
too little then
and you could consider the two-party
unconditional secure protocol for
computing the product from scratch which
of course we know we cannot do right and
so does this happen well so here's the
players right and and and these are the
so the point is if i send i said you
have to send team messages right if you
ain t minus one well those t minus 1
messages can only involve with most see
players right so those are the guys
there that communicate so i take those
two guys i'd take another another player
of that particle and now i make a
two-party protocol so Alice has input as
input value a and chill emulate those
those three guys in their head I have
Bob who will emulate just you know Lucy
now that Lucy what she called in English
I forget but if this woman in a red and
and then the idea is that that we will
now based on the publication gate
protocol do a secure commutation of a
time speaking this is easy right because
first we exchanged shares of the input
values and then we Alice and Bob will
emulate this is this protocol in in in
their heads which doesn't require
communication right because it all
happens analysis head and we end up with
shares of a and B which a times B which
we exchange and this is going to be
secure right because you know by pi PI
assumption on the publication k protocol
it's possible for one party to emulate
to simulate the shares of the other
party because because by assumption that
that was the only thing it happy it's
the only information that's in that that
approach sharing so that that's pretty
trivial actually so so this means that
then any gate by gate protocol for worst
case circuit must have communications
like you know enzyme circuit size and
depth motion circuit depth so that for
work it so what that means is is safe
for a very tall and skinny circuit where
the structure is such that you really
have to do the multiplications one after
the other if you go gate by gate so that
that could happen of course but obvious
an obvious question is what if the
circuit is nice and allows many
multiplications in parallel can we do
better than in that case and of course
many of you will say of course we can
write because we have packed sequence
so we know how to do this right the cats
though is of course that that this only
works as a number of players goes with a
number of fellow multiplications right
so basically if this would this would be
very nice if there are several protocols
from sergeant exploit this that if you
allow the number of players to grow
basically like the circuit with a
something like this then then I could
make do with the much much less
communication so the obvious open
question now is so it's I don't know the
answer maybe you guys can figure it out
quickly so for constant number of
players show that the multiplication
gate protocol like I defined it for you
multiplications must have communication
on with you this I don't know how to
show yes in sequence so what I mean is
that is is that this multiplication k
protocol will take as input you pairs of
Secrets hearings of values and it must
output you know you output sets of
shares that might contain the right
thing and be secure in the same sense as
I said before so so as you and this is
what pack secrets and allows you to do
big because because to optimize on
because because they're your she has
only 1 11 fun-filled value even if if
it's the echo secret is a u vector say
so they can do better but again the
number of players must grow so if I keep
a constant that's depend on you what's
going to happen so for communication I
don't know how to say anything I do know
how to say something about the
computational complexity of this thing
so say just for simplicity and it's to t
plus 1 and passive security and assume
that this is hypothetical multiplication
gate protocol which is defined like I
explained before and there's some play
at P that doesn't work too much he only
does little o of you local
multiplications actually this cannot be
and the reason why that's the case is
because you cannot construct the
two-party protocol for the
pre-processing model as follows so I'll
take T players not P is not among them
Alice will emulate those two players
Bob will emulate another T players then
we're going to emulate p using pre
process data and some protocol like
speeds for instance right so so what
we're going to do is we're going to say
we're going to secret share the data of
P additively between Alice and Bob and
then we write down p is the circuit this
circuit only contains little o of you
multiplication case right so so with
speeds we know that that we only need
pre-process assist data that's of a size
proportional to the number
multiplication gates in the circuit
we're doing which corresponds to pee in
this case the blood player p so so this
means what i can now compute you
products securely using little overview
pre-process data and there are bands for
for this moment says you can't do this
so there's for instance being fined
votes legged from Krypto 11 i think
they're all so so what what they did was
was active security statistical security
I think there are early results that
also talk about perfect security so I
apologize if I'm if I'm leaving out
someone as you're the remote here but so
so basically this this this says
everybody has to work hard it doesn't
show that everybody has to send a lot so
that this I still don't know how to show
you can generalize this so so if if say
you had to T plus some more players say
because you were using practical sharing
then you can do a similar thing and you
basically end up showing that that those
methods well well you know from packed
secret sharing are pretty much the best
you can do according to this this this
this contradiction here I'll talk
constant fact
in addition to what they do that's fine
I mean do I I'm only after the size of
the P process data and that size of data
only depends on the guideway emulating
so I mean I I'm fine if it is still a
contradiction even the thousand pop work
really hard good so so so now for for
something which is not quite so to
revealed so so what about this ounce
majority and reposting for processing
same question as before so say we have a
multiplication gate protocol for this
model here now of course what I was
reducing to before was if there was a
multiplication gate protocol that
doesn't communicate enough this would
imply a protocol for the two-party case
that computes the product and that's the
conviction but of course that doesn't go
to conviction anymore right because
because he know how to do this so so
that that doesn't work anymore but we
still have these the only other thing we
really know about is is we have lower
bounds on the amount of pre process data
and again brings on bootleg it gives you
actually a query broadway / 12 of
balance it so they basically say if you
want to compute a function you look for
certain combinatorial properties of that
function and and this will this will
imply a lower bound on the amount of pre
process data that you must have in order
to to to compute the function securely
so i don't have time for the details
here but but basically you get the same
as all this before so so if there was a
multiplication gate protocol it doesn't
communicate enough this implies the
protocol in this process model that's
too good to be true according to make
language later that's a long story but
but but can be done so okay I should
probably put this on the slide but but
in
the exact results you get depends a
little bit on what the output secret
sharing looks like if it's like speeds
where's additive secret sharing it
really is exactly what I say here it
could be some different secret sharing
of course some something with you no
more vendors in this year something more
complicated in that case we can't quite
show this what we can show is that no
matter what the output secret sharing is
if the goal is computing shares of an
inner product of two vectors so that's
the generalization of just one product
right so is that vector is long enough
then I still get a consultation so so it
kind of says in general no matter what
the target outputs scheme of secrets and
that you're taught that you're shooting
for as long as you compute enough there
is a point where you have to communicate
a lot so so the conclusion here is that
even with pre processing gate by gate
protocols will require this this this
you know familiar complexities that we
know already so it if nothing else at
least says that if you want to improve
all these protocols we know you will
need something different so one thing
did this this is a little bit like what
what what I guess Mike was talking about
that one thing this result might tell
you is is where should you break the
rules if you want to improve this so one
thing that that I'm led to think about
here is the fact that that may be the
the fact that we require every time I do
a multiplication engage that the output
secret sharing only determines the
product is maybe an overkill right it
implies we need this for the outputs of
the entire circuit of course but who
says we needed foot for the internal
wires because we never open those things
right so I don't know that it's
conceivable at least that there is some
crazy multiplication k protocol that
would actually give you you know shares
of coax yes of the product with the
right so I sold but but it's just
instigate contains some traces of the
inputs in the distribution of this
year's she allowed that maybe something
can be done because I used all these
properties you know
essentially in the impossibility proof
yeah so um let's do we get yeah okay so
so of course the obvious open question
is is it really true for any protocol
that I'll just forget by gate things
that you have to have these complexities
of course for computation right so i
mean if if i do n time circuit sighs
communication that top so that's all
solo banton on the work I need right and
I my conjecture is that that you didn't
you do need that much computation and at
least for the for the dishonest majority
would pre-processing scenario I think
there is some intuition that that would
sort of lead you to that conclusion at
least so the question is so I'm the only
honest guy in the world right everybody
else is corrupt they do knows nothing
useful I still manage to compute the
circuit so it sounds like I have to do
all the work myself right so that that
would that would sort of leads to the
conclusion that that probably everybody
has to do as much work as a circuit
sighs right that's that that would that
would that's in two months and waving
though because because it's conceivable
that maybe we could split the work so
you have to remember that that in that
model with this honest majority we
allowed to abort right we don't have to
compute the circuit so we could imagine
that maybe we split the work among us so
I I do apart and Adam doesn't part of it
does apart and others apart and then
somehow we combine this together to the
entire resolved and and we give each
other's short proofs that we did the
right thing so with computational
security this would work actually this
might work but the problem of course is
is that if I want unconditional security
here I need really really short proofs
that you know unconditionally zero
knowledge or and unconditionally sound
which we don't have they still exist
actually so so so I guess some some
overall plan to watch this might be to
say well if you had a hypothetical
protocol that seems too good to be true
maybe it implies that you could actually
give some of these
you know very short proofs that don't
exist well uncle additional security so
but I have no idea whether this is going
to work out communication I have
absolutely no idea ok so I'm not sure
how much time we have right ok I should
end up so I before I shut up I have one
announcement so so we have posted PSD
positions available in hose courtesy van
a venir sequent that we just got and so
if you interested studying the theory in
practice of npc you should talk to me be
it if your postdoc candidate or or
physical PSD strip okay thanks
great interesting that like we were very
patient online is essentially a charity
one of these is limitation speaking is
there any reason that we think we have
to have an information-theoretic online
what is a low battery yeah nope nope I
think I think what will be fine
attractive about information to vertical
is you secure protocols of course is
that they tend to be really
computationally simple that's what we
like about them yeah so but but could we
get this way it's in some other way and
maybe I mean when I was